halloween have always combined rousing
rock riffs with catchy melodies my
god-given right is the title track of
the new album from the Hamburg power
metal outfit
my god-given right as I need to touch it
the Toronto as the title says it's about
your god-given right to do what you
really want and thank God we did with a
muppet on we did it in them it's tough
at first when you say you want to be a
musician people say you can't live off
that I say following your dream is more
important than just chasing money on my
god-given right the band recorded the
new album on the Spanish island of
Tenerife at singer andi deris studio
manning the controls yet again was that
trusted producer charlie bar fight it
could it be bomb the basic idea was to
capture the feel of those early
Halloween years in the 1980s Austin
octagon also listen yeah we wanted that
fun factor to make the story it's easier
to digest lighter if I'd only his
sources up
the band originally formed in 1984 there
to pot album people of the Seven Keys
chartered in Britain Japan and the US as
well as Germany they were living the
dream ticket before while she won't be
the one like any band we wanted to get
out there before we'd always hope music
would see us through we wanted it to be
enough to live off and not to end after
two years there was always a bit of a
vision behind Halloween
but of a 1990s experimental forays into
the world of pop left fans cold the
singer and drummer left the band
performed pretend to their heavy metal
roots and began to tour the world
haloween went back to their
no-holds-barred best but there was also
a dark side to their newfound success
their tallest woman walking all shifting
from that rock and roll lifestyle back
to family life can be really tough it's
a high price to pass up less than them
as much size
in 2013 their 14th LP straight out of
hell was a hit around the world and the
band's highest ever charting album in
Germany they hope its follow-up will
match that success you know it's a
really open and accessible record
similar to the previous one most fans
thought the last LP was pretty great I
reckon it'll be similar with the new
record to love you for her
the pumpkin heads us their fans call
them are getting ready to hit the road
in Europe before touring the u.s. next
spring most of Halloweens members are in
their 50s now but they're showing no
signs of slowing down
right my god-given rights